bring in robert costa cbs news chief
election and campaign correspondent bob
good morning i often talk you up as a
author best-selling reporter with bob
woodward your book peril and the reason
came clear yesterday that the committee
itself referenced your work what did
they say and what did you make about
their case regarding the pressure
campaign from president trump on vice
president pence
good morning great to be with you the
committee did reference a scene on
january 5th 2021 why is it important
because it's the peak of the pressure
campaign one-on-one trump and pence in
the oval office trump pleading with
pence to go along with the eastman plan
to throw the election back to the state
maybe even into the house of
representatives pence ultimately
resisted as a mob gathered on
pennsylvania avenue
retired federal judge
michael luddig was the star witness
yesterday at one point he was talked
about as a potential supreme court
nominee by republicans
what did you make of his testimony why
was it significant
it was significant because he closed his
testimony by saying that former
president trump and some of his
supporters remain a quote clear and
present danger to american democracy
that january 6 he argued was not some
sporadic episode this is a continuing
problem related to the rule of law and
the acceptance of truth in the united
states
the committee also wants to speak to
jenny thomas a conservative activist and
the wife of supreme court justice
clarence thomas what are they looking
for there
there's so much to learn from testimony
from ms thomas recall that it was just a
few months ago that cbs news and the
washington post broke the story about
jenny thomas's text messages with trump
chief of staff mark meadows now they've
obtained emails between ms thomas and
john eastman they will probe both of
those fronts asking questions about
whether she ever had conversations with
justice thomas about cases on the
election coming before the supreme court
bob costa out in front for us once again
bob thank you very much